hey everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily so I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are evan is
currently an investor in my business and
he's mentoring me to help me grow my
coaching practice and are inviting all
of you guys to join me on my startup
journey so I started my coaching and
speaking practice 10 months ago and at
the beginning of any business it's
important to boost rep make sure that
your expenses are as low as possible
however as your business grows it's
important to invest your money back into
the business now you can keep it small
if you like and remain a solopreneur and
it's very fulfilling for a lot of people
but if you want to create a powerful
business have impact and share your
message the best way to do it is through
hiring the right people to help you as
soon as you can you want to bring on
someone on a part-time basis because if
you wait until you're able to afford
someone on a full-time basis you'll be
waiting a very long time so for me as
soon as I had 10 ongoing clients I knew
I had enough money coming in on a
monthly basis to pay for an assistant so
four months ago I hired my assistant and
since then I have saved a ton of time
which has enabled me to focus on the
things on grayed-out as well as the
things I really love and now I'm able to
really concentrate on growing my
business so in this video I am going to
share with you the four steps in hiring
your first employee now if you stick to
the end of this video I will share with
you the actual ad that I use to hire my
assistant step number one is following
the right time
you can start by hiring someone on a
part-time basis
again if your wait until you're able to
afford someone on a full-time basis that
you're going to be waiting a very long
time also it's a great bonus for you to
develop your hiring and leadership
skills without having too much at stake
step number two define the role what are
the things that has to get done in your
business but is not the best use of your
time you need to start thinking of
yourself as a CEO what are the things
that the CEO needs to focus on in order
to grow the business what are things
that you need to give up right now once
you figure out what those things are
then you will know the type of person
you are looking for step number three
write the job I I personally love using
up work however everything is remote so
if you are looking for someone in person
then you might want to consider another
source like LinkedIn and Craigslist so
when you're writing your job ad you want
to include these four elements number
one what does your company stand for
knowing your one word your single most
important core value have that in your
ad so for example my one word is
extraordinary some people might look at
that and say this is crazy and I don't
want to be extraordinary
that's fine while other people might
look at as a yeah I love this I want to
be extraordinary so right from the
beginning you're already attracting the
right people number two what kind of
person are you looking for and be honest
about it
if you are looking for a compassionate
person then put that in your ad again
some people might look at that and think
that it's stupid like who cares about
compassion and that's great that's not
the right company for them while others
might look at it and really resonate
with them they may think that hey I'm
compassionate too I think this would be
a great company for me to work at number
three what is your company culture and
be honest about it if you are a quirky
person then use quirky language in your
ad
if you're a corporate person they use
corporate language in your ad the idea
behind this is that you are hiring the
right person to fit well with your
company culture instead of trying to
convince someone after the fact for what
are the job duties so put in everything
that's required for this particular role
now a special tip understand that for
most people it only takes him a few
seconds to apply for a job so for me I
had a big giant ugly paragraph because I
am NOT detail-oriented and I need
someone who would pay attention to
details and within that big ugly giant
paragraph I buried a hidden aquestion so
if the applicant did not answer the
question they were immediately rejected
because why bother reading power letters
and resumes when they didn't even bother
reading your ad okay so we're getting a
much closer we're doing a really good
job in qualifying the applicants and now
you only have the people who really care
about your mission and again if you
stick to the end of this video I will be
sharing with you my actual ad that I
used to hire my assistant step number
five create the page while job ad
reading resumes and cover letters as a
giant a waste of time because it doesn't
actually test people for the skills that
is required for the role the best way to
do it is to partner up and work on a
small project together now Evan has gone
through this process many times over and
in his experience there's always one
person who rises to the top and that is
your guy or girl for this job now this
might be the end of the process for you
and you've already found the right
person for the role however I took it
one step further and I want to share
with you a bonus step in having the
applicants try your product or service
so for me my clients are extremely
to me and anybody who's gonna work for
me they need to know firsthand what my
clients go through so I was down to the
final two applicants and I walked them
through a coaching session with me so
for you you need to decide is it
actually important for your applicants
to try your product or service isn't
even a possibility
but I wanted to give you the option
either way and I have a special shadow
for Tracy folder Tracy thank you so much
for your support and writing that
awesome comment in my last episode and
your love and encouragement always means
the world to me the question of the day
is what is your business or your dream
business write in the comments below and
I'll join in on the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me I feel like I'm growing learning and
changing and it gives me the comfort and
knowing that all of you guys are with me
every step of the way so thank you so
much again and I'll see you guys very
very soon bye bye personal assistant who
wants to make people feel extraordinary
do you believe in the extraordinary do
you want to help change the world if so
then I would love to invite you to join
my extraordinary mission I dream of a
world where we can all move towards our
true potential I work with awesome human
beings through my one-on-one coaching
and speaking to groups of people I've
been a one-woman band but even I know
that I can't change the world all alone
I'm looking for an assistant to join my
world changing journey if this sounds
like something that resonates with you
reply to this job listing and in the
first line and leave the answer to this
question how many subscribers does Lily
Moz YouTube channel have I am constantly
growing and change is a huge part of my
life in business so I need someone who
is adaptable my assistant extraordinary
will also possess ninja level
organizational skills which you will use
towards emailing research and scheduling
but your duties may evolve as my company
grows I'm in it for the long haul so I'm
looking for someone who I can develop
and be a contributor towards my mission
you will start at 10 hours per week
spread over 5 days thus you'll be
required to work 2 hours per day but the
goal is to expand this role to more
hours like me if you are inspired to
wake up every morning to make the change
you wish to see in this world what is
your mission let me know your mission by
sending it to me on Instagram in the
morning because I want to see what makes
you extraordinary I work as a part of
Evan Carmichael's team he has hired a
hundred and twenty people on up work and
has a five-star average review we're
looking for the next member to join our
family long term and hope it's you the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details